[Music]  many local families are  still struggling to put food on the  table but you can help  tomorrow the boy scouts of las vegas  will be out collecting food at smith's  locations across  town it'll all be donated to the  salvation army  it's one of the biggest food drives of  the year for the organization  and as you can imagine it's needed more  than ever  the need is so high i mean it's it's  kind of one of those things that you  think it's going to end  things are getting better but then you  right now we just have the repercussions  of everything that's happened  it helps our young men provide service  to the community  and they have fun doing it secondly it  really does help  they can see what it helps other people  if you'd like to stop by with a donation  again it's happening tomorrow from 8 am  until 4 pm